[Musik]
Tatort Deutschland die crime Doku von
Bild
Johann Joachim Winkelmann geht als der
Begründer der Klassischen Archäologie
und der modernen Kunstwissenschaft er
wurde am 9 dezember 1717 als einziges
Kind des Schuhmachers Martin Winkelmann
und seiner Ehefrau Anna Maria geborene
Meier in Stendal in der Altmark geboren
in der wenige Meter vom Geburtshaus
entfernt liegenden Petrikirche ist der
am 12 dezember 1717 getauft worden ähm
Mirko Anfang 1764 erschien Winkelmanns
Hauptwerk die Geschichte der Kunst des
Altertums Winkelmann hat hier die
Entwicklung der Kunst anhand der Abfolge
ihrer stilperioden dargestellt und dies
hauptsächlich am Beispiel der
griechischen kunstveranschaulicht Mirko
das ist schön und gut aber viel zu
harmonisch das hier ist ein
schrecklicher Mordfall hallo okay
Natalie wie du meinst
Winkelmann auf einer Heimreise von
Italien nach Deutschland bereits
erkrankt hätte um im Frühjahr 1768 als
er in Triest auf ein Schiff nach Ancona
wartet versucht sein Mörder ihn mit
einem Strick zu erdrosseln
schließlich wurde der Gelehrte grausam
erstochen das war am 8 juni 1768 und
Goethe schrieb dazu und wie ein
Donnerschlag bei klarem Himmel fiel die
Nachricht von Winkelmanns Tode zwischen
uns nieder da sind wir also mit einem
wahren Mordfall der ziemlich lange her
ist aber nichts von seinem Schrecken
verloren hat hallo ich bin Natalie
Strauß und ich bin Mirko Kasimir und
Liebe Natalie nach unserem sehr steilen
Einstieg sollten wir uns diesen Johann
Winkelmann buchstäblich mal in Ruhe
betrachten oh ja gute Idee Mirko damals
gab es natürlich noch keine Fotos aber
auf Zeichnungen und Portraits in Öl
blickt uns dann ziemlich schlanker Mann
entgegen mit dunklen sehr großen wachen
Augen Winkelmann hatte einen eher
schmalen Kopf und einen vergleichsweise
hohen Haaransatz er guckt auf diesen
Bildern freundlich aber ein bisschen
Ernst ich würde sagen erste Typ
Geschichtslehrer der schon okay ist mit
dem man sich aber lieber nicht annehmen
möchte ich sehen möchte ich vor mir und
das passt auch zu seinem Lebenslauf den
wir ja schon angefangen hatten
Winkelmann fällt den Stendal im heutigen
Sachsen-Anhalt schon früh als sehr sehr
guter Schüler auf was für den Sohn eines
Handwerkers damals als ungewöhnlich gilt
Winkelmann singt fleißig in einem
liturgischen Chor um sich seine
Schulbücher leisten zu können und er
wird schon an der Grundschule zur
rechten Hand des Direktors der wegen
einer Sehbehinderung einen Assistenten
braucht wow ein Musterschüler der sich
aus ähnlichen Verhältnissen hochkämpft
Respekt ja und so geht es auch weiter
Natalie sein Rektor in Stendal empfiehlt
den jungen Johann einem Kollegen in
Berlin weiter und so darf er dort Kurse
an einem Gymnasium besuchen heute würde
man vielleicht von sowas wie hoch
Begabtenförderung sprechen oder so genau
es ist auch zeitlich begrenzt in Berlin
wohnt Winkelmann beim Schulleiter er
passt auf diesen Kinder auf er bekommt
jetzt die beste Bildung die es in dieser
Phase des 18 Jahrhunderts gab
Staatsverfassung
Naturwissenschaften griechisch oh seine
Eltern müssen so stolz gewesen sein
bestimmt wobei sein dortiger Rektor
schon damals vermerkt der Schüler sei
auf Lateinisch ein
homovagus at in Konstanz zu deutsch ein
rastloser und unsteter Mensch und das
zeigt sich in den nächsten Jahren denn
nach anderthalb Jahren Förderung in
Berlin kehrt Johann nicht zu Mutter und
Vater zurück sondern geht an das
Gymnasium in Salzwedel da will er sein
griechisch perfektionieren und nach dem
Abschluss dort zieht er nach Halle um
dort zu studieren ganz schön knackig
unterwegs der junge Mann ja und nein es
fällt ihm schwer Dinge zu Ende zu
bringen er besucht in Halle Kurse in
Theologie Rechtsgeschichte und
Naturwissenschaften aber er findet für
sich keinen roten Faden also verlässt
Winkelmann die Uni Halle ohne Abschluss
und wird zwischenzeitlich Hauslehrer
dann studiert er in jener Medizin okay
ja eine ganz andere Richtung aber auch
das zieht er nicht durch wir galoppieren
hier durch seinen Lebenslauf der bei der
nach ihm benannten
winkelmann-gesellschaften nachzulesen
ist also allein daran sieht man ja dass
er trotz all dieser Viren noch etwas aus
sich gemacht hat der gute Johann sonst
würde es ja keine Gesellschaft mit
seinem Namen geben oder ja korrekt
witzige Vorstellung eigentlich stell dir
mal vor es gibt später irgendwann mal
eine Natalie strauß-stiftung ich würde
es dir gönnen und dann eine Stunde da
was die berühmte Radiomoderatorin und
Podcast darin war in ihrer Jugend
Cheerleaderin passt gerne Schokolade und
wollte unbedingt beim Hörfunk zunächst
Wetter dafür werden später förderte die
vielfache Milliardären Audio Talente in
aller Welt ach das gefällt mir boah
finde ich finde ich gut doch wenn du
mich auch förderst aber ich hoffe anders
als Winkelmann wirst du nicht später
heimtückischer maulit oh ja dann
verzichte ich nämlich lieber auf den rum
schauen wir mal wie es mit Johann
weitergeht nach der medizinsache in
Halle landet er jetzt als Hauslehrer bei
einer reichen Familie Lambrecht in
Hadmersleben südwestlich und Magdeburg
er unterrichtet den Sohn Wilhelm die
beiden jungen Männer verstehen sich gut
und so folgt Johann Wilhelm schließlich
in eine Lateinschule im benachbarten
Seehausen und unterrichtet dort die
beiden Männer verstehen sich gut heißt
es also das ist vielleicht ein guter
Zeitpunkt um mal über Johanns
Ausrichtung zu reden nach allem was
diese Biografie hergibt war erwischt
schwul oder ja davon geht die Forschung
mittlerweile aus und die
schwulenbewegungen in Deutschland sieht
ihn sogar als frühen Vorreiter als Ikone
der Homosexuellen in einer Zeit in der
das noch unaussprechlich war okay aber
lass mich raten an dieser Schule im
kleinen Seehausen hält es ihn auch nicht
lang oder exakt Latein gefällt ihm nicht
so gut wie griechisch und die Schüler
und der Ort sind ihm zu provinziell also
zieht er weiter wird diesmal
Bibliothekar beim Reichsgrafen Heinrich
von bühnau auf Schloss nöthnitz das
klingt auf jeden Fall schon mal richtig
fürstlich hätte es ihnen endlich mal
länger an einem Ort oder wie sieht's aus
immerhin sechs Jahre sechs Jahre in
denen er in all den Werken über die
Antike schwägt und zum echten Gelehrten
wird und die tolle Zeit wird noch
dadurch gekrönt dass ein Gesandter des
Papstes auf dem Schloss zu Gast ist und
dieser Mann vom Vatikan ein sogenannter
nunzius ist schwer beeindruckt von
Winkelmanns wissen und Gewitztheit er
stellt ihm sogar einen Job in den
Bibliotheken Roms in Aussicht wow das
heißt unser kleiner hyperaktiver Hannes
bekommt jetzt doch noch die Kurve aber
unter einer Bedingung er muss Katholik
werden und das macht er auch durch die
Hochachtung des Vatikans wird auch der
polnische König August der dritte auf
ihn aufmerksam und fördert ihn
finanziell
wir können das jetzt hier mal abkürzen
Natalie Winkelmann wird in Rom zu einem
der wichtigsten Kunstexperten Europas
und er vertieft sein Wissen noch durch
Reisen nach Florenz oder Neapel
irgendwie sind wir schon wieder auf so
einem schönen geistigen Trip in die
Kunstgeschichte lasst uns wieder schöne
Musik dazu anmachen
ein bisschen schöne Zeit haben wir aber
nicht mehr so viel also
1763 wird der deutsche Johann Winkelmann
von Papst Clemens dem 13 zum Aufseher
über die vatikanischen Altertümer und
Chef der Bibliothek Anand er hat es also
weit gebracht mittlerweile ist der 46
Jahre alt und hat die Sicht der Welt auf
die Kunst der Antike verändert er sieht
nicht das strenge Rom als Ursprung
europäischer Kultur sondern das
demokratische Griechenland und hier
endet er wer was der Kulturteil dieses
Podcasts also ich finde das alles sehr
wissenswert
zumal Winkelmann auch Goethes spätere
Sicht auf Italien geprägt hat aber jetzt
kommt der Krimi Teil na endlich also wir
schreiben das Jahr 1768 im April tritt
Winkelmann zusammen mit dem Bildhauer
bartholomäusche wie eine Reise an die
beiden wollen nach Deutschland und ja
heute würde man wohl sagen sie wollen
Networken in der Kulturszene von Leipzig
Dessau und Berlin auch Hannover und
Göttingen waren Ziele aber die Reise
wird zu einem Fiasko Winkelmann wird
krank findet die Reise Etappen
anstrengend und fühlt sich irgendwann
regelrecht depressiv also brechen die
beiden Johann und Bartholomäus in
Regensburg ab und drehen um und auf dem
Rückweg besucht Winkelmann mal eben noch
kurz die Kaiserin Maria Theresa in Wien
also so ein Promi ist er mittlerweile
ihre Majestät überreicht dem Kunstkenner
als Ehrung mehrere Gold und
Silbermedaillen aber auch das bessert
die Laune offenbar nicht Winkelmann
fühlt sich in den quälenden
reiseabschnitten in den schwankenden
Postkutschen Hunde Elend nächster Halt
ist das norditalienische Triest das
damals noch zu Österreich gehört hier
machen die Reisenden Stationen im Hotel
Locanda grande Reisen ist damals einfach
noch sehr beschwerlich in Triest warten
Johann und sein Freund auf ein Schiff
dass sie bis an krona fahren soll von da
soll die Reise auf dem Landweg runter
bis Rom führen aber das Schiff verspätet
sich winke man lernte Motel seinen
Zimmer Nachbarn Francesco angeliquen der
gilt als ein hochkarätiger Koch ist aber
bei seinen adligen Wiener Arbeitgebern
in ungerade gefallen denn er wurde bei
Diebstählen erwischt
aber von dieser Vorgeschichte weiß wen
kann man offenbar nichts er zeigt da
kann Julie stolz die Medaillen die in
Wien bekommen hat ein Fehler am Morgen
des 8 juni treffen sich der Kunstexperte
und der Koch wieder in einem Salon des
Hotels aber diesmal gibt es keine netten
Gespräche Ark Angelie attackiert
Winkelmann und versucht ihn mit einem
Strick zu erdrosseln er will unbedingt
an die wertvollen Gold und Silbermünzen
kommen der Gelehrte wert sich jetzt
zückt der Angreifer ein Messer
Winkelmann versucht die Klinge
abzuwehren und verletzt sich dabei die
Hände er kann Geli sticht sieben Mal zu
der mörderische Koch entkommt mit seiner
Beute und winke man bleibt
lebensgefährlich verletzt zurück aber er
atmet noch und ihm bleiben mehrere
Stunden indem er den Tag Hergang
schildern kann sechs Stunden bleiben
Johann Joachim Winkelmann noch zu leben
Zeit in der er sagen kann der Koch
Francesca Angeli hat mich überfallen
gewirkt und niedergestochen er ist mit
meinen Münzen geflogen
die Behörden nehmen die Verfolgung auf
und fassen den Täter kurze Zeit später
in einem Prozess wurde ihm die Tat
haarklein nachgewiesen sogar so etwas
wie Gerichtsmedizin kam damals schon zur
Anwendung und nach Ansicht der
untersuchenden Ärzte waren fünf der
sieben Messerstiche lebensgefährlich so
modern diese Autopsie vielleicht war das
Urteil viel recht barbarisch aus er kann
Julie wurde durch das sogenannte Rädern
hingerichtet das heißt er wurde auf dem
Boden fixiert worauf eben mit einem
großen schweren Rad nach und nach alle
Körperteile zermalmt wurden boah das ist
aber brutal Winkelmann wurde übrigens
nicht in Rom oder in seiner Heimat in
Sachsen-Anhalt bestattet sondern im
Gemeinschaftsgrab eines Klosters in
Triest und noch etwas wollen wir euch
nicht vorenthalten kein historischer
Mord an einer wichtigen Person kommt
ohne wilde Theorie aus auch dieser nicht
ein holländischer Autor schlug in einem
Buch 1998 folgendes vor
Winkelmann sei bereits im Mai 1768 in
Wien während eines dortigen
Krankenhausaufenthaltes verstorben
danach habe sich ein Unbekannter seine
Wertgegenstände und seine Identität
genommen andere zweifelten am Raub als
Motiv deskriminellen Kochs und glauben
er und Winkelmann hätten in den Tagen im
Hotel in Triest eine leidenschaftliche
Affäre begonnen die mit einem
eifersuchts-markt endete auf jeden Fall
dürfte der Mord im Jahr 1768 der
absolute News Knaller gewesen sein ich
meine das eine Art europaweiter Kunst
Influenza brutal ermordet worden nachdem
in einer der wichtigsten Königin
anfangen hatte das ist ein krasser
kostet für die damalige Zeit kein Wunder
dass es auch zahlreiche Anekdoten über
Winkelmann gibt eine geht so der
legendäre Casanova der ja wirklich ein
Zeitgenosse Winkelmanns war erwischte
letzteren angeblich mal in einer
eindeutigen Situation Kommentar
Winkelmanns wenn mich schon mit der
griechischen Antike beschäftige will ich
mich auch mit den Praktiken der
griechischen Liebe befassen halli hallo
ja vielleicht beenden wir das ganze
jetzt doch lieber ein bisschen
mitgesitteter Musik das Skript für
diesen Podcast hat Stefan Netze Bank
geschrieben und er hat auch die Aufnahme
geleitet und anschließend geschnitten
Postproduktion wie immer durch Wake
world München ich würde sagen da haben
wir wieder viel gelernt heute ich hoffe
wir hören uns wieder bis ganz bald eure
Natalie und euer Mirko